he is Adrian Wojnarowski here on the
Rich Eisen show I appreciate you finding
time for us when your phone's probably
blowing up Adrian thanks for joining
RIT's thanks for having knew you bet so
let's start what's happening in
Cleveland Adrian right now
who's answering the phones in Cleveland
for any trades or making them assistant
general manager in Cleveland Kobe Altman
is manning the phones for them there's
still some there's still some executives
left in the front office but Kobe Altman
who's well respected assistant GM there
is is running the show any interim as we
reported yesterday Chauncey Billups is
Dan Gilbert's number one target to
become the new president he would
potentially hire a general manager of
his own he's meeting with Dan Gilbert
today and so that that's a possibility
there that if that process moves along
they could have new leadership in place
relatively quickly
so how would LeBron feel about that I
guess is the question that that's
uncertain that remains to be seen I
think he had a great deal of respect for
David Griffin obviously they had a lot
of success together being Gilbert Dan
Gilbert's relationship with most of his
GM's sort of deteriorates over time and
I think they just see things differently
going forward there and you know he made
the change never offered Griffin a new
contract his current deal expires at the
end of the week so that will be a
question going forward of how they
restructure a front office with LeBron
heading into once again his free agency
next summer well I mean should should
Cavs fans in your estimation be
concerned here Adrian I mean this is a
crucial 48 hour 72 hour period I don't
need to tell you you know I'm sure I'm
pretty obvious cap cabman rich should
absolutely be concerned that this is the
kind of upheaval that especially with an
executive at David Griffin who's well
respected around the league who's done
not only done a good job in Cleveland
but is
I did a good job in his time in Phoenix
and was part of a lot of success there
and and so and really built a really
good front-office really good underlings
with him and Cleveland who were in
demand around the league so that's not
easily easily replaceable and and if it
is Chauncey Billups so I think has all
the characteristics you need to be a
very good NBA executive who he
potentially hire as a general manager is
certainly very important because no
matter how good your instincts are it's
a difficult this is a that is a very
difficult situation to be learning on
the job and to have to make some really
key decisions that would impact their
future impact LeBron Jameses future in
Cleveland very quickly so there's no
question that this is a telltale time
for that whole organization Adrian were
Janowski of Yahoo Sports joining us here
no doubt with many windows open in front
of him phones and computers and plugged
in like nobody else up right now here on
the Rich Eisen show kristaps porzingis
is on the block as we're currently
sitting here having a conversation
that's happening well yeah I reported
this morning that Phil Jackson is
contemplating the possibility of moving
kristaps porzingis he is the team and
porzingis have not spoken since the end
of the season porzingis left he skipped
his exit meeting frustrated with what he
feels is the continual dysfunction and
upheaval within the organization went
home to Latvia has been in Europe this
summer and the Knicks have not been in
contact with him and Phil Jackson as I
reported met with lorimar Keenan from
Arizona who's a comparable player 7-foot
jump shooting not not the prospect that
porzingis is but met with him last night
in New York had dinner they're thinking
about marketing at number eight in the
draft if they were to move porzingis
they see market in his potential
replacement they are not engaged in any
serious conversations that I'm aware of
around the league on porzingis right now
but teams are calling there's a frenzy
of interest in
porzingis around the league teams are
calling the knicks that they're trying
to find a way to get a deal done for him
before you know maybe before ownership
or somebody else gets involved here it
would be a wildly unpopular move and a
tremendously risky move a player of
porzingis is talent it just doesn't come
along if there's one thing Phil
Jackson's done right in New York it was
drafting kristaps porzingis you know he
he's 21 years old and the idea of moving
him this quickly is is shocking to the
rest of the league but Jackson is
thinking about well I mean so what's the
plan what would the plan be should start
from scratch would some with somebody
who buys into what Phil wants to do and
Dolan keeps buying into Phil I mean
seriously what would the plan be to take
a purple unicorn like him at age 21 and
and flip him for more young players I
can't
I mean rich I can't begin to explain it
or understand it if it's because Phil
wants compliance with his players once I
mean there's no more like team oriented
goal driven hard-working everything
you'd want in a player porzingis gives
you just cares about all the things you
want a player to care about and loves
being in New York loves playing for the
Knicks doesn't want to leave and that's
what's so perplexing about this this
isn't a player who doesn't want to be
there this is a player who desperately
wants to be there but only wants that
there become some some that the
dysfunction goes away there which has
been you have a coach in an owner excuse
me a coach and a general manager who who
you know is a coach and Jeff hornacek is
being asked to run a triangle system
that he doesn't know well players don't
want to play in it and even porzingis
has been fine but let's stay with let's
stay with something and so it's
perplexing and there's no question that
there are a lot of teams virtually the
entire league would love to be
opportunistic here and steal kristaps
porzingis out of New York and that's the
kind of trade that you just
don't know how you could recover from it
I don't know how you could get value for
him he's that unique of a talent agent
or Janowski a few more minutes from
Yahoo Sports the vertical joining me
here and of the first few moments of our
conversation Adrian I would not have
been asking you about had I been setting
my my interview list my question list
about 24 hours ago that it thinks
removing changes fast so fast so what is
the latest on Paul George a story you
broke over the weekend
Indiana is still soliciting offers
around the league they're still in sort
of the info gathering stage I was just
told moments ago not close on anything
although those are always famous last
words something happens in 20 minutes
but that's right now as of literally
before we get on the phone they're still
sifting through you know who's really
serious who's not you know who's just
sort of dabbling in this I do think
Indiana would like to find a deal by the
draft but it's possible they won't and
then maybe July 1 the start of free
agency is the next I wouldn't say
self-imposed deadline but the next date
that you might want to have something
done by but I think it's it's possible
that that something could get done
between now and Thursday it's just that
because teams are aware that George
wants to go to the Lakers
it really has dulled the market for him
because teams don't want to give up a
great deal whether its young players
whether it's draft picks they don't want
to give up a lot for a player they feel
very likely it's going to be a rental
just this season and then he's going to
leave but there's a few teams who
potentially think maybe we could flip
George maybe he'll love playing here we
can convince him to stay and it's worth
something of a risk and so that's what
teams are measuring as they're calling
in everybody has interest in Paul George
but how much do they want to give up and
Indiana is working hard to create a
market create a bidding process that can
get them the most return for him and
what's the Celtics plan and I ask this
in a multi-layered way the fact that
they don't go fault does that mean that
they're going to Reese on Isaiah Thomas
what do they do with all these first
round selections that they have this
year and beyond
well these picks there it's an arsenal
that they have to either continue
drafting players or to use in a big tray
to use as to use to go get an
established star player so that's what
that's the mindset they've been in over
the last few years of balancing using
the picks versus maybe using a bunch of
them to go get a star who becomes
available you know I think their goal is
a sign Isiah Thomas I don't think it'll
be this summer probably be next summer
they have their salary cap space they
need it they need to create a little bit
more to be able to bring in potentially
gordon hayward for you toms really their
number one target and free agency Blake
Griffin is a secondary target for them
but I think right now and I think they
may continue to dabble with Jimmy Butler
and see what Chicago is asking price for
Butler remains very very high and if
you're Boston you say you know we could
you know pay words of free agent if we
think we can get him we'll just sign
them into our space we don't have to
give anything up so lots of
contingencies in Boston and all those
draft picks they have allow them to have
a lot of freedom to look at lots of
different kinds of deals or acquisition
a couple more questions for you in your
conversations and all your spade work
just list the teams for me that you
think are doing work right now next
couple of days next month to do battle
with the Warriors next season who is
saddling up to try and beat that super
team right now and hit the winning now
button Adrian I I don't you know I think
he was like Toronto if they resign
Kyle Lowry Serge Ibaka you know if the
Clippers can try to keep together Chris
Paul and Blake Griffin those are teams
that I don't think necessarily
expectation of those teams are if we
keep everybody together we're going to
win it but they're trying to contend
that the thing with the Paul George
market and it gets back to this there
might be a team if this was another year
and the Warriors didn't exist in their
super team state that they do if they
just weren't such a unique phenomenon
there might be more teams willing to go
all in on one year on Paul George
because I think he could get us over the
top
I don't think there's a team out our
than Cleveland who really would like
Paul George but needs a third team to do
it I don't think there's a tea
outside of Cleveland who really believes
if you give us Paul George we can be
golden state and so that has I think
made the market less frenzied for Paul
George because you you you've got to
keep looking at the long view if you're
running a team right now you almost have
to wait the Warriors out in some ways
and but that doesn't mean teams aren't
trying they're not trying to get better
but I don't think there's anybody out
there who thinks hey were one player
away from beating that I don't I haven't
spoken to that teammate huh ask Adrian
the poll question before you send him
out the door Brockman yeah Adrian who is
Gibran James playing for in the 2018
2019 season clean you know I don't I
don't want to make a prediction okay and
I think he's going to be a free agent I
think that the West Coast does intrigue
him I think if he were to leave
Cleveland I do think the Lakers is
something he'd look at but so much can
change between now and then it always
does and how players look at everything
and but there's no question about this
Cleveland is very concerned about the
possibility of him leaving and that's
why that doesn't answer why they let
David Griffin here no good you're not
given a job they know that this is an
issue and and they know that it's a
possibility but but I don't pretend to
know the future all right what time
could people tune in for you for your
draft show on the air our draft show on
the vertical comm on Yahoo Sports
6:30 p.m. Eastern on draft night we'll
have all the picks first trades great
analysis Tom Crean from Indiana coach
will Indiana coach will be on again next
this year and we've got a good group to
cover the draft in its hole on Thursday
well Congrats on everything once again
Adrian you are the clear leader and news
and information on this front so thanks
again for calling in and sticking with
us as long as you did you got it thanks
rich you got an agent which announced
give y'all sports so Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on radio
across the country and audience if you
like some of that get some more of that
on the Rich Eisen show lap follow all
the information you see right here on
the Rich Eisen show